[Music]
this video is sponsored by best buy hey
what's up bhd here so this is kind of
funny all the years that i was in
college i never actually made my own
like best college tech or back to school
tech video
i graduated from college seven years ago
and it makes me feel old saying that out
loud but back then i was just watching
everybody else's back-to-school tech
videos and then trying to get my own
stuff together but fun fact uh the
school i went to the college i went to
actually as part of tuition gave every
undergrad student the same
hp laptop which was kind of a nice perk
it was a thick
workstation everyone had the exact same
one so as steven students we didn't
really do back-to-school computers but
we did do back to school everything else
all the spicing up the workspace and the
the dorm room and everything around that
computer either way i might be out of
school now but i finally get the chance
to make my own back to school video so i
want to do it now in 2022 when the
options are better than ever so i got 10
things for you and this video is
sponsored by best buy which just means
that all the stuff i'm going to talk
about is also available at bestbuy.com
all the links are going to be down below
in the description and you can also go
to a best buy and actually try this
stuff out in person too which is pretty
dope so first of all a computer so i'm
going to give you three options i'm
going to have a windows option a mac
and a budget option
so now something i didn't tell you
earlier at the school that i went to the
uh all the engineering and business
major students all had the same hp
laptop but then
all of the
music tech and visual arts majors all
got the same macbook pro
so it was just different software
depending on what you have to do i don't
even know if this is still true or
happening there but the point is if
you're not going there and getting a
laptop for free as part of your tuition
uh you might want to get a new computer
to match your new work so in the windows
world i'm going dell xps now college is
already expensive so it's a big extra
expense to add a high-end computer on
top but the way i think about it this is
a computer i'm hoping to use for at
least the next four to six years
straight so it's an investment in the
future for sure so the xps 13 is one of
my favorite laptops it's world class
easy to recommend here but i'm gonna go
with the 15. this xps 15 if you can
splurge is getting you an even bigger
potentially 4k oled display higher end
rtx gpu great keyboard great bigger
speakers and this thing you can expect
to handle some pretty demanding
workloads not just games in between
classes but potentially also getting
some pretty serious coding rendering
whatever you cut your teeth on at school
getting all that done so this is a good
one now in the mac world the m2 macbook
air feels like the solid no brainer i
consider the m1 macbook air because i
did keep it around and it is cheaper but
again i think new chip plus getting the
new screen new design the ports magsafe
and all that is well worth it plus
getting the new model has you
future-proofed and getting pretty
excellent performance across the board
the mac versus windows choice in college
is mostly basically comes down to
software not just games but a lot of
times literally just whatever you're
majoring in there's going to be certain
softwares that just work with certain
types of computers so that's important
but i think yeah no matter which one you
get you're getting a good one but i do
have a third option uh it's more of a
budget option and i'm also pretty
jealous if you are studying something
that can make this work but consider a
chromebook so the galaxy chromebook 2 is
my favorite chromebook right now of
course it's just chrome os so you're
doing everything in web apps note taking
emailing collaborating etc but if that's
you then this is a lightweight
well-built chromebook that should have
your back now no matter which machine
you choose
i have one
mouse recommendation and that is the
logitech mx master 3s so this thing is
quietly released a few weeks ago which
is fitting because really the biggest
update over the mx master 3 is it's
quieter
it also has a higher max dpi honestly
this is the most versatile complete easy
to recommend mouse for me and it has
been for years i've used an mx master
for a long time at this point i even
think you can game wirelessly with this
thing so yeah easy easy ad there if
you're looking for a mouse now if you
happen to be taking the right classes
and you're in the right note-taking
situation that a stylus and a tablet
actually works for you first of all i'm
jealous but then second of all uh the
ipad air and second gen apple pencil are
excellent now there are a bunch of
combos that will work for this too
samsung's galaxy tabs and their styluses
are really good and there are lots of
great note apps on android as well but
i'm going with the ipad air here and the
second gen apple pencil that snaps right
onto the side as the safe bet every time
i review the ipad i always give the
pencil a shot just for kicks obviously
artists get a lot more use out of it but
i also found that taking math related
notes specifically when there's all
kinds of formulas and structure to them
trying to keep up on a computer with a
keyboard just doesn't cut it for me so i
always have to write this stuff down but
having a virtual notebook that is pretty
sick the newest air has the m1 chip
there could be an m2 version soon by the
time you see this i don't really know
but i also don't think it matters too
much because ios 16 is still ios 16. all
right new smartphone for back to school
yeah sure why not galaxy s22 or really
anyone in that series but i think
specifically the base galaxy s22 now
that we're sort of in the middle of its
cycle is starting to see those discounts
i reviewed it back in january and it
still holds up as one of the best
all-around phones that's the thing about
the phones that come out in january we
tend to forget about them later in the
year but s22 still has some of the best
cameras the best displays excellent
battery and really good software plus
the dex features are super dope if that
happens to work for your setup maybe you
have a monitor already and you just plug
that straight in that could be cool too
so can't really go wrong with that as a
new phone also my daily driver lately
has been an s21 ultra
which is a sort of interesting fact i
don't know if maybe that's worth a
separate video maybe leave a thumbs up
if you want to see a
breakdown of that but yeah s22 now i've
got some desk accessories here that i
also really like that i've found you
know you're going off to college for the
first time you've got your dorm desk set
up you want to get some stuff going to
customize it that's what this is about
that's also desk accessories that's a
tongue twister try saying desk access
desk accessories desk
accessories but this is the college dorm
where i made videos for a whole year and
shared with a roommate i think i did
okay nice setup but these are easily
best if you have a device like an s22
for example that wireless charges so
this audi light desk lamp has a wireless
charger at its base it's a fast wireless
charger and it also happens to be a
really nice little led lamp three
brightness settings no flicker you could
go that route or just go straight up
multi-device wireless charger for the
dorm bedside this one from belkin is a
go-to pro tip if you have an apple watch
and it's the series 7 or later make sure
you look for a wireless charger that
specifically supports the watch's new 15
faster wireless charging speed it does
make a pretty big difference and then
last but not least
headphones
so if you're going off to college and
this is from experience if this is the
first time you're going to be studying
or doing homework in a noisy environment
noise canceling headphones can be a
complete game changer so that's why i'm
putting sony's wh-1000xm4
on this list i consider putting the mark
fives on here but i think as a deal the
mark fours sound just about as good but
they fold so they fit easier in a
backpack they have almost all the same
features and they're less expensive so
the mark 4s are still awesome i highly
recommend them maybe the only downside
being that they're not waterproof but
this is this is your new study hack but
the only reason i bring up water
resistance for my student athletes out
there is you can't really
work out and sweat a lot in these and
trust that they're going to
last a long time so you probably already
have a go-to set of workout headphones
but you know going off to school might
as well
upgrade so the beats studio buds have
been great for me the shape the fit the
features
the sound pretty much everything about
them they are also ipx4 water resistant
of course and there's just been so many
waves of me going back and forth between
recommending and not recommending beats
products over the years but these are
definitely on the really good side the
shape is so important they stay in my
ears for everything short of like
sprinting or jumping and landing hard on
the ground but it's rare for my ears for
something to fit this well so yeah go
get you an upgraded pair of workout
earbuds you won't regret it and that is
it there you have it my first back to
school set of recommendations ever let
me know how i did but i couldn't wait to
make this video so i was pretty pumped
about it but that's ten things to send
you back to school and hey shout out to
everyone who graduated this summer best
of luck over the next few years and may
they be filled with tech and thanks
again to best buy for sponsoring this
video everything i talked about you can
find at a best buy and of course all the
links will be down below this video to
check out as well all right
catch you guys in the next one
peace
you